on a day when he'd usually be
broadcasting to Millions Gary lineker
left home with little to say about a
crisis that seems to escalate by the
hour
the face of the BBC's football coverage
still features on the billboard at their
Studios but that face and those of many
of his fellow pundits will be notably
absent from our screens throughout the
day the disruption spread staff staying
away in solidarity meaning no Football
Focus no final score
lunchtime on BBC One now in a change to
the schedule it's Bargain Hunt
coverage on the radio was also impacted
the usual live lunchtime Sports programs
replaced with recorded shows
there's a show that's a Saturday night
institution as much for the
personalities and punditry as the
football that's become the Battleground
in a debate about free speech and
impartiality
[Music]
and stars like Ian Wright reinforcing
their support for lineker I'll tell you
something if they do vbc get rid of
garlic I'm out I'm gone I'm not staying
there on his own platform he should be
able to say what he wants to say
away from the BBC's Sky pundit Gary
Neville tweeted this is all the legacy
of Boris Johnson he continues his trail
of Destruction even when he's not in
power freedom of expression is is
becoming something that's increasingly
precious and I don't think that just
because Gary lineker earns a lot of
money uh with the which he's in in my
opinion entirely entitled
um
should deprive him of Human Rights any
more than a poor person should be
deprived of human rights for differently
there has of course been support for the
BBC's decision lineker himself sought
the sanctuary of a Premier League match
at his Boyhood Club Leicester City
there's no sign publicly at least of
either side being willing to give ground
and with the dramatic escalation in the
last 24 hours and the support for Gary
lineker amongst his colleagues if there
is no way back for him how does this end
so loud
says say it loud tonight there was a
demonstration of support for lineker
outside of the BBC what began with a
tweet on immigration has exploded into a
nationwide debate just how much it
matters to some
measured in the removal of one of the
most familiar faces in the country from
our screens Greg Milam Sky News Salford